how did the one piece World get the way
it is what's happened in this world that
looks so artificial that has Dinosaurs
lost ancient civilizations with a
technology to travel into space and a
whole Century of History completely
missing from the books during which the
world changed forever and fell under the
tyranny of the celestial dragons for
over 1 000 chapters we've now followed
the adventures of straw hats Luffy but
what's happened before he set sail on
his journey but before we start a quick
word from today's sponsor Opera GX I
actually downloaded this browser a few
months ago and haven't been using
anything else ever since so I was more
than happy that they actually reached
out to work with me for sponsorship
using this browser is just a no-brainer
for me it's designed for gamers and you
really can't tell the user interface is
beautiful and so freaking customizable
I'm a real sucker for Craig getting my
own designs for everything and I found
this pretty dope one-piece wallpaper
here for example that's just awesome for
my fellow Gamers Opera GX has CPU RAM
and network limiters so you can get the
most out of both gaming and browsing I
love this little feature here that lets
you pop out a video as well and it has
these super useful sidebar Integrations
as well for example Discord or Whatsapp
makes it super quick and easy to access
it whenever I need and it's also hooked
up to my Apple music or Spotify I guess
if you use that and if you want there is
a mobile version as well and if you
download it using my link in the
description below you will get an
exclusive feature in your GX corner
where you will be able to see my last 12
videos we've gotten tons of bits of
pieces from characters tragic
backstories to glimpses of ancient
history but with so much lore in the
story at this point it can be hard to
remember all of those details so today
we're going to go over the official
timeline of everything that has happened
in one piece before Luffy finally set
sail we're gonna cover everything up to
Roger's execution and if you enjoy that
well we can cover the great pirate era
until Luffy's journey in the next video
like I don't know if you knew this but
one piece has like a whole lot of story
before the story a long long time ago
long before we have any official record
keeping in the one piece worlds we know
a few things we know that there were
once dinosaurs that ruled the lands that
have now mostly gone extinct now they
just survive in pockets of the grand
lines such as little garden and of
course they live on an ancient Zone
fruits like those possessed by the Beast
Pirates we also know that long before we
have any official dates there was an
advanced civilization on the moon that
appears to be the ancient ancestors of
the sky Islanders and perhaps the
lunarians but now though we're still
waiting for confirmation on that maybe
our favorite archaeologist Nico Robin
will be able to help us out with that
one so far so good but now let's
actually get to events that we have
actual accurate dates for thanks to
aichiro Oda himself let's start with the
oldest known event in all of One Piece
for this we have to go back a whole 5
000 years with the planting of the tree
of knowledge by the ancient residents of
the island of Ohara remembering that the
tree was 5 000 years old and that the
library contains so much of the
knowledge from all those Millennia makes
Robin's flashback and that tree burning
down just hit that much harder while
moving up a whole Millennium from the
Tree of knowledge we moved to Alabaster
where the palens in arubana was built
four thousand years ago it would make
sense that Alabaster would hold some of
the oldest known events since we do know
that Alabaster was one of the kingdoms
that originally formed the world's
governments like many centuries ago and
in Alabaster we also learned a few
pieces of its history from Robin when
crocodile has her desire for the PO
monoglyphs she didn't tell him that it
holds information about the ancient
weapon pluton instead she recites some
other pieces of alabastian history from
her memory however we're not exactly
sure when these took place because
they're dated according to a different
calendar than the standard calendar used
in one piece fun fact did you know that
the World building in one piece is so
detailed that they have multiple
calendars it's like the standard
calendar that the story follows that is
referred to as the age of the sea cycle
but then according to Robin's
information on the alternate age of
Heaven calendar in 239 someone named
kahira conquered Alabaster in 260 of
that calendar the betin dynasty of Tamar
began its rule in 306 the great top
Temple was constructed and in 325 the
great hero of altea mahmudin did
something what we don't know because
crocodile stopped her right there thanks
for nothing real realizing that he
wasn't getting the information that he
actually wanted now of course it's also
possible that instead of reciting actual
historical information Robin was just
you know lying and making all of that up
is that really likely then skipping
further ahead to 1 100 years ago we have
the building of the city of gold
shandora and its prosperous age on the
blue sea 100 years after that we have
the birth of zunisha and around 1 000
years before the current story The Minx
found Zoe on top of zunisha's back
though it was already there and that's
of course when we're starting to get to
the good stuff 900 years ago we have the
beginning of the Void century and I
really wish that I could tell you more
about what happened in this 100 Year
time span but we'll just have to wait
for Oda Sensei to reveal the true
history the little that we know is this
the ancient Kingdom ruled the world with
the power of the ancient weapons but by
the end of the Void Century they were
replaced by the alliance of 20 kingdoms
spread around the globe including
Alabaster and resrosa that would become
the world's government this Alliance
that became the world government then
proceeded to erase all mention of that
ancient Kingdom from history including
its name so the only thing that remains
of the Kingdom's history are the nearly
indecipherable pornoglyphs these are
these incredibly old ancient
indestructible stones with a really old
language that were crafted in wano
during the void Century we don't know
exactly how the ancient Kingdom fell or
how the world government took power but
surely once the story reaches love tale
we're in for some real bombshell
Revelations what we do know is that
during the void Century there was a
figure named Joy boy who played a
central role there his comrade the
elephant zonesha committed some terrible
crime and was sentenced to walk the
ocean endlessly for Century up to this
day during this time Joy boy also broke
a promise to the leader of Fishman
Islands to work with Poseidon to raise
the Noah and it was also during the
century that lady Toki used the time
time fruit to fling herself into the
future where she would then meet kozuki
Odin also during the century the great
city of shandora then also fell to the
alliance of the 20 kingdoms however the
shandians remained on Jaya to defend
what that remained of the city of gold
and now after the void Century 800 years
before the current story all of the
rulers of the 20 kingdoms who formed the
world governments leave their home
countries to reside in marijua where
they and their descendants become the
celestial dragons the ruler of the world
that is all but the rulers of alabaster
who remains on the Sandy Islands however
it does include the donkey hot family
who leave the kingdom of dressrosa at
which point the Riku family became its
new monarchs the Riku family delivering
an apology to the Donata who had been
enslaved by the donkey kot family 100
years after the ending of the Void
Century which brings us to 700 years
before the current story in this Century
the world government orders the
construction of a bridge on tequila wolf
which is for some still unknown purpose
and is still being built to this day
it's exactly where Robin was teleported
to during the time skip jumping ahead to
500 years ago we have the life and death
of the ancient giant oars whose body is
preserved in the icy nordlands who knows
maybe he would have survived had he had
pressed the Flaming red box that is the
Subscribe button well never know 400
years ago The Adventures of Mont Blanc
Noland begin this legendary Adventurer
traveled to Green bits where he becomes
a hero to the tontada later during this
Voyage he arrives on Jaya where he
befriends khalgara however four years
later when he tries to bring the king of
his country to the City of Gold shandora
had already he been shot into Sky Pia by
the knock-up street thinking Noland a
liar the King has him executed
tarnishing The Mont Blanc name for
centuries 300 years before the current
story The germa Kingdom sanji's family
was at the height of its power the
German Empire spanned the entirety of
the North Blue for 66 days and ever
since they've longed to grow their power
to something resembling this previous
state make German great again I guess
200 years ago the world government forms
an alliance with the fishmen and their
Hugo Kingdom attends its first reverie
however they would not attend another
one for over 200 years until the most
recent reverie turns out racism isn't
quenched that easily now 100 years ago
we finally started to get some much more
familiar characters and events with life
spans the way they work in the series
will start to see a lot of people who
appear in the story or who get more
fleshed out in Flash backs relevant to
our timeline and main characters right
now and that of course starts with the
beginning of Dory and bragi's legendary
duel on little garden this also leads to
the spreading of the Giant Warrior
Pirates without their two captains the
remnants are captured by the Marines but
mother caramel convinces the Marines to
let them go after returning to al-bath
with the Giant's mother caramel founds
the Sheep's house orphanage basically a
front for her human trafficking ring 81
years ago we find ourselves in wano
where we'll be spending a considerable
amount of time for the rest of the
timeline this is when the head of the
kuruzumi poisoned the other Daniels of
wano to try and attain the position of
Shogun however with the birth of kozuki
sukiyaki the Kazumi Clan loses all its
power and its members are hunted down
beginning the long feud between these
two houses 63 years ago a young
Charlotte Lin Lin is abandoned by her
parents on elbaf and taken in by mother
caramel caramel plans on selling the
powerful Inland to the Marines after
witnessing the toddler easily
dispatching several fully grown Giants
and on linlin's sixth birthday she ate a
delicious Kraken Boucher with a sight of
mother caramel and gained caramel's
devil fruit power the soul soul fruit
together with Streisand who found the
lone linlin they founded totland and
whole cake Island 59 years ago both
Kazuki Odin and kaido are born not funny
that they're the exact same age thus
began Odin's wild childhood exploits and
rise in his Infamous reputation during
Odin's childhood many other significant
events happened around the world as well
shimotsky Village is founded in the East
blue the Rumba Pirates also befriend
laboon and leave him with crocus before
meeting their very tragic demise in the
Florian triangle the only Survivor being
broke thanks to his devil fruit
meanwhile the Giants oimo and Kashi are
tricked into working for the world
governments and so while Odin's
notoriety increases so does kaidos with
the vodka Kingdom declaring him the
ultimate Soldier and attempting to sell
him to the Marines for admittance into
the reverie meanwhile while Odin is
creating a harem and kaido is escaping
from the Marines a number of times a
young Charlotte katakuri tries donuts
for the very first time soon after he
tears open his mouth eating too many of
the tasty treats at once ouch 44 years
ago kaido joined the legendary rocks
Pirates presumably around the same time
other Pirates such as big mom or Shiki
join as well just two years after that
shaki gives up pirating and starts a bar
on Saba ODI archipelago 39 years ago
Odin is exiled from the flower Capital
but then he reforms kudi and becomes its
new daimyo in the very same year the
Raja Pirates become the first crew to
make it to lodestar Islands officially
the furthest point you can go in the
grand line so far 38 years ago the god
Valley incident occurred when the Rocks
Pirates attack odd Valley home to the
celestial dragons GARP and Roger join
forces to fight fight them during the
battle rocks presumably dies and God
Valley completely disappears from the
map afterwards GARP is hailed as the
hero of the Marines also kaido gets his
legendary devil fruit there and the
Roger Pirates discover a small
red-haired child in a treasure chest
five years later or 33 years ago donkey
cut homing gives up his position as a
Celestial Dragon and takes his family
with him from marijua meanwhile the
former members of The Rocks Pirates
kaido big mom and Whitebeard begin
recruiting members for their own
personal Cruise back on wano Inu arashi
mikumamushi and kawamatsu become Odin's
retainers then 30 years ago Odin meets
Whitebeard and joins his crew along with
Neko mamushi in orashi and izo and while
sailing he also meets his wife Toki who
as you remember traveled into the future
all the way back from the void Century
earlier meanwhile much more important to
the story Monkey D GARP punches Don
chinchal so hard that he rounds out his
hips 28 years ago Roger discovered first
that he has a terminal illness and the
Roger pirate set out on their final
Expedition through the Grand line the
very same year Nico Olivia also leaves
O'Hara in search of the pony glyphs and
one year later while on the grand line
the Roger Pirates face off against Shiki
and the Golden Lion is left with the
most unfortunate hats of all time 26
years ago Neptune becomes the king of
the yugu Kingdom pound was kicked out of
big mom's Kingdom and young Frankie at
this time known as Katie flam was
abandoned by his parents but most
importantly this is the same year that
the Whitebeard Pirates and the Roger
Pirates had a battle for the Aegis that
lasted three days and three nights on an
unknown location Odin leaves Whitebeard
and joins Roger's crew for the last leg
of the voyage but meanwhile rochi
overtakes wano with the backing of kaido
and the Beast Pirates 25 years before
the present story and the Roger Pirates
make it finally to love tale having
conquered the grand lying Goldie Roger
is giving the name of the pirate king
and disbands his crew finally about to
die from his disease Goldie Roger turns
himself into the Marines at his
execution may be the best media stunt
pulled ever he reveals to the world the
knowledge of the one piece inspiring
hundreds of thousands of new Pirates to
seek his hidden treasure thus Begins the
great pirate era now all of this history
really leaves us with more questions
than answers plus there are tons of
other unresolved Mysteries out there
still needed to be answered like who is
Luffy's Mother where is laughtail and
what is the secret of the Moon if you
also crave an overview over all these
questions that are still open for
answers well you shouldn't miss out on
this video right here though